the jurogan experience gordon
is undeniably
the best pound-for-pound jiu-jitsu
player on earth not just the best but
pretty pretty it's a pretty good
statement to say that you're the best
ever
you're only 25 yeah that's crazy
yeah how the [ __ ] does that happen uh so
i'm gonna go ahead and give give credit
to john
i mean uh i think that without him
i maybe would have been successful it
would have been i would have been
you know maybe the best in the world at
some point in my career
but i don't think that without john i
would be where i am right now and i
don't think that i would have gotten
this good
uh in this amount of time you know i've
only i've been training 10 years i've
been competing
uh professionally for five years and i
think that
you know a big part of the reason why i
am where i am is because because of
john's coaching
yeah we're talking about john donahue
for people who don't know who is a
a literal genius and a mastermind in jiu
jitsu and
a true mad scientist and watching him
coach you guys is very fascinating
because he's so serious and stoic and
gordon ryan
pass over the left leg gordon ryan post
like the way he talks like
it's really interesting he says your
full name too it's it's real it's very
interesting gordon ryan gary toning
craig jones yeah he's always it's always
the full the full name
yeah why what is he's such an odd duck
he does it to address us
um because a lot of times like you've
got like nikki for example
like there's a lot of guys named nikki
so he make sure he makes sure you know
he's talking to you when he says nikki
ryan nikki rod
craig jones gordon ryden so you know
that you know that when you hear your
name being called your first and last
name you know that okay this person is
addressing you in a room of you know
five ten thousand people
he's such an unusual human being there
is not a single person on the planet
earth
like john donahue one of the most
brilliant guys i've ever met
obsessed with jiu jitsu mostly like
that's
if you you got a pie chart of his brain
it would be like
he's like 20 room for other [ __ ] 80
percent of his brain is jiu jitsu yeah i
mean it's not it's not even just jiu
jitsu it's just martial arts in general
like i mean people who know john on a
personal level and have trained with
john know that john knows just as much
just as much about mma as he does or
even more about mma than he does about
jiu jitsu
um he's been coaching mma with george
and with chris
weidman for longer than he's been
coaching jiu jitsu i mean he's only been
coaching
professional jitsu athletes for five
years uh and i've watched him
personally teach judo privates to judo
olympians
watch teach him have him i watched him
teach wrestling privates to wrestling
world team members wrestling olympians
um you know he knows just as much about
the other martial arts as he does about
jiu jitsu it's crazy
yeah and never walks around without a
rash guard on which is also correct
which is the honest thing i've seen him
one time ever
with a rat with uh with a t-shirt on
because uh
we went to long island to train with
chris chris weidman one time
and uh he forgot his change of rash
guards so he had a street rash guard on
and he didn't have a second rash guard
to change into and chris didn't have a
rash guard for him so they gave him like
this pink flamingo t-shirt
that he ended up we did a whole session
with chris weidman it was right before
he was gonna fight luke rockhold the
second time which ended up never
happening
but uh we did this whole session with
john with like this pink tropical
t-shirt on
and then he changed out the t-shirt to
get back into a street rash guard and
leave to go home
like it was just like i'm just like okay
this is happening i posted it everyone
was freaking out about it
just how crazy is it that he has a
street rash guard yeah he's got his
he's got street rash guards he's got uh
training rash guards and he's got like
his nighttime like dinner
date rash guards like he's got like a
date rash guard he's got a dinner rash
guard
like he's got it all he's got it all
sorted out so if he goes on a date with
a woman he wears a rash guard
oh yeah he's got like he's got like this
really nice like underarm like this gray
under armour sweatshirt that or
um rash guard that he puts on and like
you know like when john
comes out in one of his fancy rash
guards you're like okay he's not [ __ ]
around now
you're like this guy's like you got to
do like all right this guy means
business tonight
has anybody ever asked him what the [ __ ]
is going on yeah i mean so he just
he just likes to wear rash guards
because of the fact that they dry fast
um the fact that they're cool they keep
you cool they keep you warm
if they get wet they dry fast um and
they're just tight fitting he likes
tight-fitting clothes
um so he just he just prefers to wear
them he thinks they're more efficient
than t-shirts are
it's just it's just so odd but that's
part of john donner always has a fanny
pack respect
i respect the fanny pack one of the
great mysteries of the world is what he
has inside that fanny pack
it's kind of thick it is he's a large
fan he's got a lot of stuff inside there
he's uh it's just it's so fascinating to
watch
what he's done in coaching this don her
death squad and create
like he's unquestionably the greatest
jiu jitsu coach on earth
and this is also widely regarded like
the way you're
widely regarded as the best pound for
pound grappler he's widely regarded as
the best jiu jitsu coach
and it's it's um it's really interesting
to see that
you guys just have been dominating the
grappling scene
and to watch all this play out and to
see people study you guys
but still not be able to catch up
yeah i mean what most people do is they
just see like a general outline of what
we do but
no one looks at what the specifics of
what we're doing they say oh you know
gordon's a good leg locker let me try to
do leg locks or gordon's trapping hands
from the back let me try to do that
but they don't see the very specific
details and the specific details are
what's going to be the difference
between
finishing a high level guy and having a
high level guy escape
so what everyone does is they just see
the general idea and have the general
outline of what we're doing and they try
to just copy that
but when you just try to copy the best
guys if you just try to copy everyone
else you get the same results as
everybody else you have to go further
than what the best guys are doing
you have to innovate and you know i look
at the other best guys in the world and
i say what are they doing
you know that works against the other
high level guys and how can i make that
better
not just let me try to arbitrarily copy
what they're trying to do
now what is missing in like if you take
the rest of the people that are in the
top ten
like what are they doing differently
what everyone does in jiu jitsu is they
try to do the least amount of work
possible
to win a jutsu match right so
they try to jump past your guard they
score an advantage they score a couple
points
and then for the next seven minutes they
do nothing whereas
what we try to do is we try to take the
hardest route to victory and we try to
submit the guy
so what you see is a complete there's
just a complete different minds
a completely different mindset between
what the rest of the guys are doing and
what we're trying to do
we're trying to go out and we're not
we're not satisfied unless we hit a
submission and in my case sometimes i
call the submission and
i'm trying to you know go out and hit a
specific submission
um but you know they're happy just going
out and
having a match for this ten minutes in
the feet they just hang on each other's
collar ties
and then they win a rough decision and
they run around beating their chest like
they just
they they did something so just the
mindset and
the mindset for winning and competition
is completely different
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience